boulay Kev Janai is here go watch our
interview it's out right now you got
some dope records out we're gonna have
to perform one of them yes 4 P.M in the
Ville 4 P.M in the Ville coming soon
coming soon This song is called
Introducing let's go
[Music]
oh
no I don't need nobody else now
feeling like the hero of my city say
Daddy [__] with me I'm a boss and
plus I'm prettier
I could see the snakes I'm feeling Envy
every time I start to win it start to
change the energy yeah but [__] imma
keep going if I had a witness they would
never know I it's a lonely road to the
top and True Colors showing but I
question every move I made before I
looking in the mirror see my future and
I'm that [__] conversations where my
mind like Mama we gon be rich but I
gotta make it through the Wilderness
already gotta hit listen once I start
shooting better small town girl from The
Ville with some Big Dreams it's just the
beginning but I like to introduce me
[Music]
wherever I go my past knocking at the
door
begging for me to hold on
see my past something I can't change but
the pleasant is a gift that's the
gateway to the Future that I've been
praying for someday get this when nobody
gonna take it away no no no no no no we
get done for yourself
believe me baby you won't need nobody
else
foreign
[Music]
thank you thank you that was incredible
thank you that was fire whoa hey I know
you just watched a new freestyle guess
what we're dropping them every week
sometimes more than once a week Jesus
we've been dropping a lot lately uh
shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week